hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay got two
fuses and I think I'm headed back
towards the bus where the first sign
said that I needed a fuse but what the
fuses are for got me but obviously I
need them back then away back here oh
yeah this is by the tree of death need
to go to Hanson Square where that was
handsome arrogant
Saxon heaven
I don't even oh there it is Saxon after
station
guess it's over there whatever
hello tree of Doom destruction obviously
I'm not supposed to go I go back there
we go okay now we need to find a s'more
feenin to get rid of these fuses what
okay I hope I'm going the right way
because they haven't thrown a monster in
my way that may be a sign that I'm going
in but the only thing that I can go on
is that the first time that I was told
that I needed fuses was at the bus on
the map like he all saw so I just have
to hope the right way but it's probably
not I probably left the apartments early
okay now how do I go back to grab my
fuse I also need another one why why do
you need it that is the question why why
why why
for the bus somewhere confused over bus
find them maybe it was for another
subway I don't know I don't know I'm
kind of at a loss here I'm not getting
any enemies I pulled one piece of the
subway I pulled one from the school or I
pulled the one from the school to put in
this stuff
but I have no idea why I need to get
these shoes when at one point did Simon
realized that he needed uses like for
what for what purpose for what reason oh
he was in the bus like it just it just
doesn't make sense what I have to go
into my career that weren't any monsters
I can only do so go down only assume
that I went the wrong way I went through
the sewers for nothing
balderdash those two monsters don't
count that I fought and killed because
they were already there
and what there's some other way please
explore all fall on the stairs to be you
know my monsters let's not let's leave
like back to the apartments anyway
probably nothing
yeah that just leads down there so not
where I want to go so love a waypoint
an objective something in my journal
that hasn't been updated in forever this
is there's nothing in here
it's just journals that are already
doesn't help me no objective simon
document what you're supposed to do all
right let's go back go back to the
apartments why would they want why would
they give me the UH nobility to get a
ladder and get out of there in the first
place if they didn't want me to leave
it's just puzzling I don't want to crash
down here all of that Oh Gary noise
I missed something that's my fault
please I've been reading the comments
you guys don't know what's going on
either well some of you do because you
play in the other case you haven't
played just as lost as I am because I
never got an objective I'll be fine if I
just make my way back from whence I came
get out of here getting out here come on
now saman climb fast business I'm going
back into the apartments that's just
there's no way around it I just got to
go back because obviously I missed some
did I miss something and I just was I
supposed to get to the other way because
I'm so lost it's just you know it just
sucks being lost that a it holds my
progress it holds to you guys is
progress but oh well I guess it's okay
jump down maybe I jumped down too soon
maybe maybe we'll find okay that led to
that I can't jump back so maybe I could
try to find like the front entrance of
this apartment and try to get out that
way because maybe maybe I'm supposed to
go back to the very beginning I've been
backtracking me a bit so I don't see why
not
hello Ben guy
that's fine
shut up good man not even a little bit
punching here let me do the most ear
whoa a bag of trash just jump-scare me
this limit tap that dawned on me
okay that's a way out stairs over here
lots okay I think that might have been
where I came in from the very beginning
so remember this is like yeah my secret
note one when I first came in that's the
first punch this one get down and
there's the do not enter horrifying door
if I go up here there's nothing
absolutely DubLi okay so yeah I had to
get out right I'm so lost lost why do I
need the fuses punch your glasses
oh I don't know oh I don't know can I
pick this up with what road flare
donator Oh flare all right accomplished
something I got a nightstick maybe I was
supposed to go back to the subway oh
come on
ah all right that didn't take long did
it
aw crap
crappy crap crap I'm in though I loaded
the wrong save sorry all right guys
d'arnot okay where was I
no that was the right save oh yeah I top
that say when I came back in okay few
bid
I got them for you but I tap that
because I didn't wanna lose probably cuz
I'm smart alright yeah this is where I
came in and this is where I go okay I'm
right I'm right here
okay so we basically found then that's
not where I need to go I was supposed to
I'm supposed to get back out that's just
the long and the short of it that's the
only way that could have happened it's
the only thing that could I don't know I
don't know I feel like I've just been
going in circles one of them what am I
to do is I've got two fuses the only
places I know to use fuses is the school
and the subway so I'm just going back to
the subway I don't care if there's not
monsters in my way or what I'm going
back this subway that's fine I'm putting
it in it and then I'm gonna look for
another place in the subway further to
put another I pulled another fuse and
then I'll just go my merry way
I loved it I would give this game a 10
on 10 if it would just give me some
detective so far I really like it's
supposed to like if you lose the
character and he dropped the pacing
between stairs that throws off first in
the game and then it just kind of loses
its traction as a horror game oh you
guys have faces right now we go back
from whence we came once again hope this
looks familiar
oh hello everybody welcome to pawnch
pawnch I'm going back to the subway
nothing you can say goes
got me nothing nothing will stop me here
near up the level make it out and then
go through the bus go through the booth
and they get back to the subway
maybe that's just where I'm going can't
stop me now can't stop me now all right
absolu ID me to go back at someone
because they need it so I will go back
and these guys can suck my ball did I go
back this way only one yeah yeah I think
so I think that leads to a dead end cuz
I did I didn't the roof jumping and then
I couldn't get any farther than that
okay big guy I know big man big man was
big we dodged in here
walk right by heart to get to the subway
I suppose I suppose I could have gone
that whole way back to the subway after
I went back to the apartment because I
could have jumped through the bus at any
time I didn't have to go back then and
get it so maybe that's why there aren't
enemies in front of me it's because I
killed them all before when I was
backpacking trying to get from the
subway maybe we shall see
it still doesn't answer the question why
does why does he need to go back in the
wording it said specifically I need to
go back and get my fuse that's what
exactly what he said if it comes to it
like if it comes to it after this I'm
not in the right direction I'm just
gonna go I'm gonna be lost forever
trying to wander to please I'm not the
kind of let's player that just wants to
fulfill time even if it's just me lost I
don't want to feel time I want to get
things done I'm done time and manner and
entertain you guys with scares of terror
and all wrong okay
now let's see mm-hmm oh I'm scared every
time it looks just read now that is
gonna break it likes to dare okay that's
all the time I got for this part thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next part
bye bye